this video is made possible by blinkers
the first hundred people to go to blink
East calm /by graphics are going to get
unlimited access for one week just to
try it out you'll also get 25% off if
you want the full membership more about
that a bit later on but for now let's
just get on with it
[Music]
Henry Ford was an American success story
through his dogged perseverance
engineering brilliance and innovative
production techniques
he brought an affordable motor vehicle
to the masses creating an empire in the
process and yet there were other aspects
of the man that didn't really fit
comfortably in to the American icon
image from his anti-semitism to his
vehement opposition to unions Henry Ford
was a man who defied description and in
the days by graphics video we're gonna
get close and personal with Henry Ford
[Music]
Henry Ford was born on July the 30th
1863 in Greenfield Township Michigan he
was the oldest of five children to
William and Mary Ford William was an
Irish immigrant while Mary was a
first-generation American of Belgian
heritage the Ford family they were
middle-class farmers Henry was
particularly close with his mother who
he absolutely adored the children worked
hard to help their father perform the
day's labor
Henry pitched in enthusiastically though
he never really enjoyed the work he
later commented I never had any
particular love for the farm
it was the mother on the farm that I
loved Henry he disliked school much
preferring to study on his own terms
hit huge amounts of curiosity and this
was mixed with his creativity by the
time he had reached his teens
Henry was obsessed with gadgets he had a
habit of taking apart watches and then
putting them back together he did this
over and over again until he could do it
in a matter of minutes his reputation as
a watch repairman it began to grow and
soon he was maintaining the timepieces
of everyone in his neighborhood when he
was 13 Henry saw a steam powered motor
vehicle for the first time he was
fascinated with it and he instantly
recognized its potential to replace the
horse as the main means of
transportation from that point on he was
absolutely obsessed with automobiles
a short while after the encounter with
the vehicle Henry's beloved mother she
died very suddenly naturally Henry was
heartbroken from that point on he wanted
to get off the farm as it simply held
too many memories his opportunity it
came three years later when he was
offered his first job he moved to
Detroit to become an apprentice
machinist for James F flower and
brothers who made machine parts he later
moved to the Detroit drydock company by
night he worked at a watch repair
company in order to pay his rent any
spare time that he had had spend on his
mechanical experiments in 1882 at the
age of 19 Henry returned to the family
farm to help his father he still hated
farming that he loved tinkering with the
farm machinery his father had purchased
a Westinghouse portable steam engine and
Henry made it his mission to perfect the
use of it he became so good on the
machine that he managed to get a summer
job at the Westinghouse Electric Company
in Detroit he demonstrated and repaired
steam engines that were used to power
heavy machinery
[Music]
when he turned 21 Henry's father gifted
him with a sizable parcel of land he now
split his time between working the land
demonstrating Westinghouse machines and
studying part-time for a bookkeeping
diploma in early 1888 he met a young
woman by the name of Clara
Jane Bryant after a short courtship the
couple were married on April the 11th
five years later their first and only
child
Edsel was born Ford now I had a family
to look after he made ends meet by
cutting and selling the timber on his
land within a year he set up a sawmill
which became moderately profitable he
built a mechanical workshop on the farm
uns continued tinkering on heavy
machinery Henry had been brought up in a
Christian household and now that he was
a family man he seemed to take religion
much more seriously every Sunday he made
an 8 mile round-trip sue attends the
nearest Episcopalian Church he came to
believe in reincarnation which was not
an Episcopalian concept rather than
finding another Church however he simply
added it to his own personal belief
system he has an evangelizing spirit
enjoying sharing his beliefs with others
about his religious beliefs he wrote
religion like anything else is a thing
that should be kept working
I see no use in spending a great deal of
time learning about heaven and hell in
my opinion man makes his own heaven and
hell and carries it around with him both
of them are states of minds
[Music]
in 1885 Ford was tasked with fixing an
auto engine a large stationary single
cylinder internal combustion four-stroke
engine designed by German Niklaus Otto
after pulling it apart and analyzing
every component he put it back together
in working form and then proceeded to
make his own version of this machine by
1890 he was working on a petrol powered
engine in September of 1891 Henry
secured a position at the Edison
illuminating company in Detroit antara
moved to the city to make a new life
within two years Ford was promoted to
the position of chief engineer along
with this promotion came a substantial
pay rise this provided in the means to
work on his petrol engine when he wasn't
working for Thomas Edison in 1896 that
countless evenings tinkering in his
homework shop they finally paid off with
the unveiling of his first
self-propelled vehicle he called it the
Ford quadricycle he presented his
prototype to Edison company executives
including Thomas Edison himself Edison
was intrigued and in fact delighted with
Ford's invention encouraged by the
praise of his boss Ford developed a mark
to model with numerous improvements
Ford's newer and better quadricycle
caught the attention of a Detroit lumber
baron by the name of William H Murphy
nothing but his money behind the young
inventor allowing Henry to resign from
edison and start his own company he
called it the Detroit automobile company
investors wanted to capitalize on Ford's
petrol motor as quickly as possible they
pressured him to rush production as a
result the vehicles produced were of a
lower quality and a higher price than
Ford was happy with having produced just
20 automobiles the company it was
dissolved in January of 1901 Ford was
more relieved than deterred with the
closure of the Detroit automobile
company with the pressure to produce no
longer on him he put his efforts into
designing and building a 26 horsepower
automobile in October of 1901 in order
to get publicity for his invention he
began entering racing competitions a
flipped sounds Lee beating the local
champion in a 10-mile race II won back
the confidence of his investors they
were prepared to back a second company
and so the four
motor company was born with Henry as its
chief engineer however the same tensions
developed as previously when the
investors brought in a consultant to
check Henry's focus on technological
improvements he left the company the new
man Henry Leland's went on to create his
own vehicle the Cadillac ins the company
was renamed the Cadillac automobile
company Ford now teamed up with a former
cycle racing champion named Tom Cooper
together they produced an 80 plus
horsepower vehicle that they dubbed the
999 this car was raised by top brace a
very old field to a resounding victory
in October of 1902 race with this
success under his belt fort entered into
a third company he teamed up with a coal
dealer from Detroit named Alexander
malcomson to form Ford and malcomson
limited he now set about making an
affordable automobile for the working
man Ford and malcomson they found a
factory and they got to work they
contracted the Dodge Brothers John and
Horace who owns a local machine shop to
produce all the parts that they needed
within a year a Ford had his new and
affordable vehicle the challenge now was
to sell it initial sales were slow which
led to a cash flow crisis new investors
were brought on board and the company
was reincorporated as the Ford Motor
Company in June of 1903 Ford's new
economical automobile was put to the
test on the ice-covered surface of Lake
Sinclair between Michigan and Ontario it
achieved a new land speed record of 91.3
miles per hour that's one hundred forty
six point nine kilometers an hour
very old field then toured the country
to demonstrate the car this publicity
brought the name Henry Ford to a wide
audience
Versailles affords new car they grew
steadily by 1905 the company it was
absolutely thriving Ford we're the only
car manufacturer who were catering to
the middle classes because of for the
automobile it was no longer just a
plaything for the rich now it was able
to be seen as a viable means of
transport for pretty much everybody now
just before we get into Ford's most
notable vehicle of course the Model T
let me tell you a bit about today's
sponsor who make these sort of longer
videos possible and that sponsor is
plinkus
look now if you're watching this channel
you're probably curious
about things I mean why else would you
commit to a 20 minute video about Henry
Ford and this is why blink test is such
a great fit for this very channel blink
astiz an app that takes the best
insights and need-to-know info from
thousands of non-fiction books and
condenses them to just 15 minutes that
you can read or you can listen to eight
million people currently use this app
and they're consuming content that's
from history to self-help the way I
consume thinkest is that my commute to
work is about 15 minutes each way so
it's perfect for a little hit of
knowledge blink astiz about 15 minutes
of audio or text to read it's really a
way to fast-track myself to the most
important knowledge from important books
one that I recently recapped with
Stephen Covey's seven Habits a book that
I've read in the past hams love blink
has provided me an amazing reminder of
all of the best stuff from that book but
it's not a central that I've read in the
first place but this is also a biography
channel so how about I recommend one of
the many books from Walter Isaacson on
that platform he's biography people like
Einstein Franklin DaVinci Steve Jobs the
first hundred people to go to blinkers
comm /and biographic is going to get
unlimited access for one week to try it
out she'll also get 25% off if you want
the full membership get it now and grab
those seven habits or maybe the
biography of Einstein or FNC again
that's completely free just go to
blinkers comm forward slash bio graphics
and let's get back to fort
[Music]
in October 1908 Ford released the famous
Model T this streamlines vehicle had a
number of innovative features including
having the steering wheel on the lefts
and entirely enclosed transmission
engine for cylinders cast in solid block
and a pair of semi elliptic Springs the
Model T was easier than anything else on
the market to drive and it was
inexpensive to repair now with the Model
T Ford introduced the assembly line
production process now he wasn't the
first to use assembly line production
procedures but he did refine it to make
it as efficient and therefore as
cost-effective as possible rather than
having a group of employees working on a
single vehicle Ford set up a conveyor
system where the car moved from one
station to another at each station a
highly skilled worker would focus on
just one aspect of the construction that
worker would then repeat the same job
over and over again this process cut
down the time to produce a Model T from
12 to only six hours as a result of
these improved practices Ford was able
to sell his Model T at the unheard-of
price of 895 dollars which is twenty
three thousand and ten dollars in
today's money this was less than half of
what other manufacturers were selling
their vehicles for as the assembly line
process was streamlines the price of the
Model T it came down even further by
1912 it was down to five hundred and
seventy-five dollars on the strength of
the massive popularity of the Model T
Ford was able to take a 48 percent share
of the u.s. automobile market by 1914 in
1913 though a multi-story factory was
built in Highland Park Assembly of the
Model T would begin on the fourth floor
with the engine then it would move down
floor by floor until the body was added
on the final and ground floor Ford set
up a network of Model T franchises all
over the country salesmen sold not only
the affordable car but also the concept
of vehicle travel and the opportunities
that came with it with the Model T the
country would be opened up to the masses
with all the wonders that it held in
store Ford was determined that his
buyers would become loyal Ford customers
for life as a result he offered an
unheard-of guarantee when he bought a
Model T the Ford factory would stand
behind you
maintaining it at the most affordable
price possible Ford was a firm believer
in welfare capitalism he wanted to
maintain a happy workforce who were
treated fairly as a result he introduced
innovative programs and benefits for his
staff in 1914 he introduced the living
wage where each worker received a
minimum of five dollars per day this
would be the equivalent of about 120
dollars in 2019 this is always double
the pay that most other companies were
offering at the time
one reason that Ford brought in the
living wage was that prior to its
introduction his factories had a very
high employee turnover rate some
departments numbering a hundred men
turned over thirty employees a year this
was largely due to the monotony of the
production line process now the increase
to pay offset the boredom of the job the
living wage allowed for to attract the
best mechanics in Detroit other
companies they were forced to raise
their wages or simply lose their workers
Ford's also did other things to ensure a
happy workforce his factories that
cafeterias water fountains health care
and company sponsored sports teams the
benefits that Ford brought to his
workforce though they came with a few
strings he expected his workers to live
clean lives in accordance with Christian
moral principles he established a social
departments which kept a close eye on
the private lives of his employees
anyone who was seen to be over drinking
gambling or not providing adequately for
their family would be subjected to an
intervention meanwhile business-wise
sales of the Model T were going from
strength to strength and drop in the
price of the basic touring car to three
hundred and sixty dollars saw sales
reaching four hundred and seventy two
thousand in 1916 every single one of
those cars was black as it was the color
that dried the fastest on the assembly
line
this led Ford to utter the rather famous
line that any customer can have a car
painted any color he wants so long as it
is black
[Music]
Ford was completely opposed to us
participation in World War one he was a
pacifist he was offended by other
businessman who profited from war trade
in 1915 he teamed up with Hungarian born
Jewish pacifist Rasika Schwimmer and
funded a peace ship to travel to Europe
and advocate for an ends of the fighting
170 leading pacifists boarded the ship
and headed along with foreign Schwimmer
to the Netherlands and then on to Sweden
the voyage did not have official US
government blessing and it soon became
the subject of intense ridicule Ford
decided to distance himself from the
enterprise and he left the ship and made
his own way back to the United States
around this time Ford began to make
public as anti-semitic beliefs he claims
that the world been started by German
Jewish bankers and that he was
collecting information that would make
that fact clear
despite its founders pacifist and
anti-semitic sentiments the Ford Motor
Company was pressed into producing
engines for fighter planes and
anti-submarine boats once the u.s.
entered the war in 1917 in 1918 at the
urging of President Woodrow Wilson Ford
ran for the Senate seat in Michigan Ford
was an advocate for Wilson's League of
Nations and the president felt that if
Ford won Michigan it could tip the scale
in his favor in Congress he told Ford
you are the only man in Michigan who can
be elected and help bring about the
peace you so desire Ford he ran but he
lost by about 4,500 votes still he did
remain a staunch advocate of the League
of Nations
a month after the end of the war in
December of 1919 Ford handed the reins
of the Ford Motor Company over to his
son
Edsel who was now 26 years old however
the father retains the right to veto any
decision in 1918 Ford had purchased a
small newspaper called the Dearborn
independence every Ford factory issued
this paper to its employees throughout
the 1920s Ford used this paper as the
vehicle for disseminating his
anti-semitic views he believed that an
international Jewish conspiracy was
working to take control of the world
between 1920 and 1922 he published a
multi-volume work titled the
International Jew historians now believe
that these books were an influence on
Adolf Hitler's worldview during the war
years Ford worked with his son to take
the Ford Motor Company to the rest of
the world a massive complex was built at
River Rouge in Dearborn Michigan this
was the world's largest industrial
complex at the time by 1929 he had
thriving dealerships on all six
continents Ford wanted his business to
become a vertically integrated company
this meant that every aspect of supply
for the company would be owned by the
company this meant that the company
wouldn't have to rely upon any suppliers
especially foreign suppliers on May the
31st 1929 Ford signed a nine-year
technical assistance agreement with the
Soviet government for who would help the
Soviets set up an automobile plant and
the Soviets would purchase 30 million
dollars worth of knocked-down for trucks
and cars Ford sent his best servicemen
to the Soviet factory to train the
Russians
by the mid-1920s the Model T sales they
were dwindling competitors were
producing competing models some of them
with more powerful motors and better
features it was time for a new model to
roll off the production lines the Model
A Ford was released in 1927 the car was
available in a range of styles including
sports coupe a truck and commercial
unlike the Model T it was available in
four colors the Model A was another hit
for Ford with sales to 1931 topping 4
million by 1931 a third of all
automobiles throughout the world were
made by the Ford Motor Company in the
late 1920s Ford began building airplanes
the most popular was the Ford 480
tri-motor commonly known as the tin
goose Ford for this was honored by the
Smithsonian Institution for changing
aviation history
Henry Ford hated labor unions he was of
the opinion that they served only the
self-interest of labor bosses who were
detrimental to workers he felt that he
was perfectly able to look after the
interests of his works and saw no need
for unions on his sites in order to
scare off union activity ford employed
former navy boxer harry Bennett at his
service department then it was not
averse to using violence to squash union
activity on one occasion he men beat up
United Auto Workers representatives as
the police simply looked on this
incidents which became known as the
Battle of the overpass was widely
reported it hurt Ford's reputation and
it increased support for the Union that
saw Ford recognized that there was a
need for a collective bargaining
agreements with the unions however his
father vetoed the idea of him even
talking to the unions in April 1941
there was a sit-down strike which closed
down the River Rouge plant Ford prepared
to shut down his entire business rather
than deal with the Union it was only the
intervention of his long-suffering wife
Clara that brought him to his senses
with the recalcitrance of the old man
out of the way had sort managed to sign
an agreements with the United Auto
Workers Union in June of 1941 Ford's
obsession with blaming the Jews for the
world's ills intensified over the years
his newspaper the Dearborn independent
published 91 consecutive articles to
riding Jews Jewish leaders responded by
calling for boycotts of Ford cars in
1927 he was sued for libel the case it
was settled out of court shortly
thereafter Ford agreed to shut down
production of his newspaper in the early
1920s Ford had been given a copy of a
book called the protocol of the Elders
of Zion which had been produced by the
Russian Czars Secret Service in the
early 1900's it painted a damning
picture of the supposed worldwide Jewish
conspiracy Ford he believed every word
of it however within a few years it was
exposed as a fake when Ford learned of
this he was horrified and he offered an
apology to the Jewish community assuring
them of his future friendship and
goodwill
despite these words Ford continued to
denounce Jews throughout the 1930s he
did business with Nazi Germany up to and
including the warriors at the same time
he produced b-24 bombers for the US
military Ford is the only American
mentioned favorably in mine Kampf
speaking in 1931 to a Detroit News
reporter Hitler said that he regarded
fort as his inspiration this explained
his reason for keeping Ford's life-size
portrait next to his desk
Hitler revered Ford stating that I shall
do my best to put his theories into
practice in Germany and modeling the
Volkswagen on the Model T in May 1943 49
year-old Edsel Ford died of stomach
cancer Henry now aged 80 was forced to
run the company once more yes he was not
a well man having already suffered from
a series of strokes and heart attacks he
was at the helm for two years at which
point he handed the reins over to his
grandson Henry Ford the second Henry
Ford's retirement was short-lived he
died of a cerebral hemorrhage on April
the 7th 1947 at his Dearborn estate a
hundred thousand people showed up at his
funeral to honor the man who brought
private transportation to the masses so
I really hope you enjoyed that video as
always do give us a thumbs up subscribe
if you liked it hit the notification
bell so you'll find out when we put out
a new video and also do check out
today's sponsor that's blinka steel find
a link to them below its really great
stuff just go check it out now before
you watch something else why not and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]